as if you didn't already suspect that
Nikki Haley's 2024 Republican
presidential campaign was off to a bad
start we've learned that she has been
dramatically overstating the amount of
money she has raised and the campaign
looks to be I don't want to say Dead on
Arrival but very very close so the
Washington Post reporting Nikki Haley's
campaign vastly overstating her
fundraising listen to this instead of
the 11 million dollars touted by her
campaign
Haley brought in about 8.3 million not
all of which can even be used for the
presidential campaign they had been
talking about 11 million in six weeks
but now that the filings have been made
with the FEC that was an over
exaggeration the campaign appears to
have double counted money it moved among
various committings committees the
filings covering the first three months
of the year show that three committees
affiliated with Haley collectively
brought in 8.3 million
um
Haley's joint fundraising committee
raised about 4.4 million the campaign
committee's Hall of 5.1 million included
1.8 million from that other committee so
a bunch of that money was double counted
and this is all being considered highly
unusual the Trump campaign Saturday said
they brought in about 14 and a half
million and then another 4.3 million
into the leadership pack and on and on
and on now the funniest part of this is
not all of that 8.3 million can actually
be used for the campaign
because the leadership pack is
um typically only to boost allies or to
promote a message not directly to
finance her own campaign so listen this
is pretty bad
this is pretty bad and there's two ways
to interpret this one way to interpret
it is the fact that Nikki even raised
eight even though she can only use a
fraction of it that's already amazing
for a candidate who isn't doing that
well in the polls the Counterpoint would
be this is probably the most attention
she will ever get this was the big
moment
and she still wasn't able to raise that
much money and it didn't do anything for
her in the polling and indeed the
polling doesn't look very good uh her
best poll right now is a particular Iowa
poll which which has her in third place
at 14 behind Trump and a guy who's not
even running yet Ron DeSantis that's her
best showing most polling has Nikki
Haley at two three or four percent for
example in the Kentucky primary she's at
four percent in the Georgia primary she
is at four percent so a couple different
thoughts here one I don't think we had
to wait for these numbers from both
polling and fundraising
to be able to say this campaign's
probably not going anywhere at the same
time there's the perspective that the
campaign doesn't really need to go
anywhere in the sense that
Nikki Haley I mean listen you know
people have asked me before when someone
like Nikki Haley announces given what
the polling is does Nikki Haley actually
think she can win I don't know the
answer I've never actually asked these
candidates
do you don't really think you can win do
you
um
I'm sure she wouldn't admit it if she
didn't think she could win but there's a
particularly unique situation in this in
this 2024 Republican primary which is
Nikki Haley could be running as an
audition for VP that's something that's
been discussed and that I think should
be considered and not ruled out sure she
might be running for VP Trump certainly
seems to think that she is and also
there is the usefulness of more
candidates to Trump because when you
look at 2024 polling one of the things
that you'll notice is in head-to-head
matchups between Trump and DeSantis
DeSantis does better not better than
Trump he's still mostly losing to Trump
but he does better than when you have
Trump DeSantis Haley Pence Tim Scott
Vivek ramaswami and whoever else the
more candidates you have
um the better it actually is for Trump
so there's also the speculation or the
idea that Trump liked the idea of Nikki
Haley running because it actually helps
him needless to say this is a campaign
that as a presidential campaign was
doomed from day one as a vice
presidential audition remains to be seen
uh and we will indeed see that as I've
mentioned before I supplement my diet
with vitamins every day I've tried
different methods none have been simpler
or more cost effective than just a daily
scoop of ag-1 from our sponsor athletic
greens with the one scoop I get the 75
high quality vitamins and minerals from
whole food sources that I want I'm
covered for the day I'm not messing
around with different vitamin capsules
and then some have 200 and some have 180
so they run out at different times and
it's a mess it's a mess this is simple
The Taste is good it you can put it in
water juice or shakes each serving is
under three bucks a day compare that to
what all of the individual supplements
would cost you and it just makes sense
simplify your life by starting the day
with a scoop of 75 high quality
nutrients when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get a
free year supply of vitamin D I've
talked about vitamin D before and five
free travel packs of ag1 the link is
down below